-Our guests tonight are
three of my favorite people.
Please welcome back
to the show my family,
Hillary, Larry,
and Josh Meyers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, everybody.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Year 10 of the tradition.
-The tradition lives on.
And it's very nice to have
you here in person, Dad.
Last year, you were via Zoom
because you got a COVID
diagnosis right before you came.
And it worked out great.
And, Mom, you said last year,
that was your favorite vibe.
-Yeah. I managed
to finish sentences.
-You did.
That was the weird difference.
Everybody was finishing
their own stories.
-Yeah.
-But I have to ask mom.
-None of that tonight.
-No mute button.
-Everything's cut off.
But I want to ask --
This is a serious question.
Dad, you retired this year.
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am now part of
the gainfully unemployed.
-Gainfully unemployed.
And, Mom,
that means he's in the house.
-Yes.
-And?
-Well, I nicknamed him
"Larry the Lurker."
-Larry the Lurker?
-Yeah.
-He's doing a lot of lurking?
-No matter where I am,
he sneaks up behind me.
I go in a room,
he's in a corner, he jumps up.
And you know
I have that startle reflex.
-Yeah.
-That's why I'm doubting
he's actually jumping out
in order to scare you.
-It's amazing. She comes
into a room, and I'm there.
-Yeah.
-That in itself is unnerving.
-I live there,
and she comes into the room
and I'm maybe
coming out of a closet,
a bathroom, or something,
and she...
It's like so -- If Jimmy Hoffa
came out of the bathroom,
she would not be more surprised.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's not a big house,
and you do live there,
so I feel like every room
you walk into,
there's like a 25% chance
he's going to be there.
-There's a good shot
I'm there, yeah,
but she just is so shocked.
-Yeah.
-It's unbelievable.
-You're also not known
for your light footfalls.
-Yeah.
-Well...
-So I feel like
you could be able to track him
where he is in the house.
-He would have
to stand very still.
Dad is someone
where you just know --
And, by the way,
I have your footfalls, as well.
People know when we're coming.
-Yeah.
-Well, the other thing is,
I have, you know,
a 100-pound sheepdog
that follows me everywhere I go.
So if I go,
if a sheepdog walks into a room,
and she hasn't figured out
that I'm coming right after her,
or vice versa --
Yeah -- She's slow learner.
That's the problem.
-I will say, you would make a
very bad detective, I feel like.
-Well, yeah. You could be right.
-Yeah, I could be right.
I will say that I just
came home a couple weeks ago,
and I always forget
that you guys
have a cardboard cutout of Josh.
And when you open the door --
A life-size cutout.
-Yeah.
-Sure.
-And, so, I am not -- I
will not blame myself for this,
but I opened the door,
and every time I walk in,
I'm like, "Oh [bleep]
Because when you walk in
and see your brother,
who you know is not
in the state, just like this...
-You're not the only one
that happens to, by the way.
Yeah.
-It was the best.
It was a Mother's Day
present during the pandemic.
-Yeah.
-So, there I am, all alone.
Well, except for...
[ Laughter ]
And then, every time
I walk in the living room,
and I see Joshy waving to me.
It's like I can go
on another day.
-And that was during
the pandemic, right?
-That was the pandemic.
-And what did you give her?
-Mine got, like,
lost in the mail.
-Yeah. Because that's why
we only have one cutout.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's one cutout of Josh.
I will say,
a two-cutout house is weird.
That was big news --
you retired this year.
The other big news --
Josh, congratulations.
You got engaged.
-I did, I did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, got engaged.
-Thank you.
Yeah.
-How -- I was caught off guard.
-Yeah, you were.
-You and your a beautiful
fiancée FaceTimed me.
And when you told me what
happened...
-You cried right away.
-...I cried right away.
-Yep.
-And I mostly because I'm like,
"Oh, I don't want to have
to go to a wedding."
No, I really did cry.
I was very caught off guard.
And how did it go down,
from your perspective?
-It was great. She's from
Shelburne Falls, Massachusetts.
-A beautiful place.
-A beautiful little town
that has this bridge called
the Bridge of Flowers,
which has been
maintained for years
by the Shelburne Falls Area
Women's Club, all volunteers.
And it's this beautiful,
beautiful old
retired trolley bridge.
And McKenzie suggested
we should walk across
the Bridge of Flowers.
It's called the Bridge of
Flowers, if I didn't say that.
And I was like,
"Oh, this is perfect.
And I ran up.
I took a shower very quickly.
And she said,
"You took a shower?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I just --
I don't know.
I was sweaty.
I wanted to take a shower."
Ring in my pocket, and we walked
across the bridge.
She crossed the bridge,
and then I was like,
"Oh, babe, there's a flower
I want you to see
over here in the middle."
-That's a real good place to do
the "There's a flower" move.
-Yeah, yeah.
Because I wasn't lying.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I wasn't making it up.
And, so, she walked past me,
I, I guess, lurked behind her
for a moment.
-It's genetic.
You know how to do it.
-And then I tapped her on the
shoulder, and she turned around.
I took a knee.
She took a knee with me.
She was like,
"Now? This is happening now?
It's happening here?"
And I said, "Yeah,
it's happening here."
And, yeah, so, you know,
we sort of crouched down.
I said my piece.
I asked her to marry me.
She said, "I'm going
to have to think about it."
Then she said, "I'm kidding."
And I was like, "Well,
I would take a 'yes.'"
Like, I'm not -- I'm gonna stay
down here until you say "yes."
So she said "Yes."
-That's great.
-And then we met up --
mom and dad were there.
McKenzie's mom,
stepmom, and her dad --
we all sort of got together
and had some champagne,
and it was --
Yeah, it was perfect.
It's a beautiful story.
And the other thing is,
I remember you told the story.
You know,
we went to college together.
We have the same
college friends,
and we were all together.
And you told this story about
how you got -- you proposed
on the Bridge of Flowers,
and all our friends
wanted to ask was,
"Were you worried about bees?"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's also -- We kept it a
secret so that we could tell --
We had a big group trip
with all these guys,
and I was telling them --
Everyone else
in this group
of our friends is married.
And so I was sort of saying,
I didn't want McKenzie
to feel bad on this trip
because she's
the one girlfriend,
and everyone and our friends
thought I was about to propose
in our friend's kitchen at night
with people she had just met.
And people went from
a state of, like, nausea
to when I said, "That's why
I proposed three days ago,
and she said 'yes'"
to just sweet relief.
-Every one of our friends'
wives were thinking,
"Oh, God, not here."
-Yeah.
-It was really good.
So, it was very, very nice.
And you actually filmed a
video on The Bridge of Flowers,
which is a nice visual aid
for the story you just told.
This is the video
we all got from Josh.
-In McKenzie's hometown,
there's this bridge called
the Bridge of Flowers.
Rightfully named.
And we were out here the
other day and we got engaged.
-[ Laughs ]
-We love you guys so much.
I'm gonna start
crying again now.
-Oh my God,
that is such a good video.
When you sent it --
originally sent it,
I only watched the first
half of it, so it's --
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
You've got that TikTok
sort of attention span.
-But, also, I'm very excited.
McKenzie is here tonight.
Can we see my soon-to-be
sister-in-law?
There she is!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And her mother, Linda,
everybody.
Well, we've got a lot
more to talk about.
It's been a big year.
We will be right back with more
from the Meyers family.